حسنًا ، يقول السعوديون إن
الرئيس بايدن سيذهب إلى هناك
بدعوة من الملك سلمان ،
لكنهم يوضحون أيضًا أن
الرئيس بايدن سيلتقي مع ولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان في الواقع إنه
مع ولي العهد كما هو متوقع على
الأقل من  وجهة نظر سعودية من
المتوقع أن تجري محادثاته الأكثر جوهرية
حول الأمن الغذائي
والعلاقات الاقتصادية لأمن الطاقة وتحسين العلاقات التجارية
حتى المناقشات حول الفضاء ، لذا فإن mbs هي
حقًا القوة اليومية في المملكة
العربية السعودية ويبدو أن هناك
اعترافًا الآن من قبل  البيت الأبيض
الذي سيصبح محمد بن سلمان هو
الملك في نهاية المطاف في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
ومن المرجح أن يظل في موقعه
لعقود عديدة قادمة.
وحقيقة
أن الرئيس بايدن يحتاج
إلى دولة ذات قدرة إنتاجية متأرجحة
مثل المملكة العربية السعودية للمساعدة
في ارتفاع أسعار الطاقة حول  إنه
عالم أنه لكل هذه الأسباب يتم تقديم
تنازلات من كلا الجانبين ،
لكن من المهم أن يكون
الرئيس بايدن قد قال أثناء
حملته الانتخابية إنه سيحول المملكة
العربية السعودية إلى دولة منبوذة الآن ، حيث
استمع السعوديون إلى خطاب حملته الانتخابية.
أنه مرة واحدة في البيت الأبيض ، كان
بايدن يخفف من حدة الأمر ومن
المحادثات التي أجريتها مع
المسؤولين السعوديين ، لم يتوقع أي منهم حقًا
أن تصبح العلاقة متوترة كما كانت
على مدار العام ونصف العام الماضيين أو أن
تستغرق وقتًا طويلاً لإعادة التعيين ولكن
يبدو أنه يعود إلى تلك النقطة التي
يتحدث فيها الكثير من السعوديين عن علاقة طويلة
ودائمة ومهمة مع
الولايات المتحدة
نيك روبرتسون سي إن إن لندن